first let me start with um this is going
to be my stupid one and it's going to go
for you okay um if Gwen and Kate Bishop
were to meet and actually get in a fight
who do you think wins it's not stupid
I've thought about it
um who do I think actually wins
wow you know
so it seems as much as I thought about
it I don't know that I have the answer I
think they're both highly highly capable
uh and and skilled
I feel like between now and when it
happens right right of course
Kate will be more experienced right
she's she's they're both very quick do
you know who what do you have um I love
Kate now I love Kate do you have an
opinion on you I I personally think Gwen
really yeah I think so too I think
Spider Sense is gonna be the thing like
you're right you're not wrong all right
yeah well I guess we'll find out right
well and you never actually know
I don't